servus und griffig zu einer neuen easy
german episode aus wien heute wollen wir
wollen herausfinden was so richtig
typisch österreichisch ist und dazu
befragen wir heute die leute da am
karlsplatz los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unsere frage heute ist was ist typisch
österreichisch alles sicher entfällt
die hauptidee andrea und vivantes
partners cvc zum klartext das sonst down
oder nur zum klavier am sonntag in die
kirche
man weiß nur überrascht davon dass heißt
du gehst du jeden sonntag
mittleres oder glauben dann hat man über
meine eltern in der steiermark bin dann
gehe ich hier von nintendo ja super und
bei dir ich nicht wusste
was ich wirklich alle und volksfesten
und was ist typisch österreich ist keine
ahnung wandern zu gehen nicht so gerne
wandern ja es geht
und dann noch sehr früh aufwachen und
irgendwelche termine anstehen sehr früh
und ja keine ahnung zum verkauf hier
irgendwo hinaus gehen auf jeden fall was
vielleicht typisch österreichisch ist
und so diese kompromisslösungen das geht
schon irgendwie und manchmal schauen und
dann schauen wir mal also das wäre was
typisch österreich ist also nicht so
klar und präzise wie vielleicht jetzt
unsere deutschen nachbarn oder so
sehr freundlich pünktlich
und
über umwelt sehr bewusst so immer über
plastik oder was die becher oder
über alternative pflanzen mich
fragen was ist so oder lieblingsspeise
österreichisch
der dhc vision ist dass künftig
kein pastor und süßes
gibt es kein
essen nehmen aus dem
paradies was typisch ist er level oder
so also kulinarisch glaube ich gibt es
sehr viele ausdrücke die typisch
österreich sind vielleicht gibt s was
menschen besonders bestellen eine
menschen oder hab ja für uns mailand und
cappuccino ist es gleich so ist kein
unterschied aber normalerweise ja sie
bestände melanie oder ein später ein was
ein spinner was ist das ist doppelter
espresso und
spender ein spieler also habe ich noch
nicht gehört ja erfolg waren und ich
habe gedacht das ist sehr
österreichische weg gar keinen kaffee
- für die zuschauer die das nicht wissen
wie genau er käme darauf geschlagen
amerika also besser wird sowie kaffee
latte oder christo viel milch wird der
kaffee latte also wie sich
sprache man in europa haben sie ja
irgendwie einen besonderen dialekt
sondern mal was passiert irgendwas was
sie vielleicht nicht gerne benutzt hat
die war scott nicht
weißt du nie zweimal 1000
und in der sprache irgendwelche wörter
die wir kämpfen
ja weil sie schon also jetzt schon sagen
schon man kann schon erkennen wenn ein
besucher aus österreich oder aus der
stadt kommt das kann ich schon erkennen
das hört man sofort ja und irgendwann
war dass du ganz gut kennen kannst du
das kennt keine ahnung servus
auf deutschland sie sagen wasser aber er
müsse ja
genau
[Musik]
wenn ihr noch mehr übungen zu unseren
episoden haben wollt dann schaut mal bei
atrion vorbei dort findet ihr weitere
aufgaben und unterstützen uns mit
unserer arbeit
[Musik]
ich kenne nur um wien reden ist reich
also ich kann halt nicht alles also ich
kenne die orte - anders ich weiß nicht
einmal nach wien kommt halt immer wieder
her kommt egal wie komisch die leute
sind es hat seine anziehungskraft ich
liebe wien egal wer auf die scheiße wien
oder auch die leute ich würde immer
wieder zurückkommen
typisch österreichisch ist oft wandern
gehen tiefer auf jeden fall
viel bier trinken
mehr gute frage also ich bin das nicht
also ist aber ich hatte gesagt als auch
auf die sprache bezogen auf die dialekte
und die einen ganzen slang denn es gibt
auf jeden fall
typisch österreichisches für mich aus
meiner sicht auch berge viele berge und
auch viele bergsport im wintersport und
ja und dann halt so dass klassischen
geschnitzte
liebling wiener oder bereich elektro
zb
es sind schon kleider
ist einfach überall weiter ist auch wenn
waren ja bis dahin oder
irgendwas typisch wienerische
avatar spielte das lied ist so wie wenn
man windows schimpfen wird
kann man bei wie dann schon sagen nein
wirklich sicher ist sicher unser top
antwort hat schon ganz
lieb
ich glaube die häufigste antwort heute
nachmittag schauen schauen
typisches
leiva leinwand
sie bekommt from austria
sind elegant und klassisch
elegant
freundlich sehr freundlich nicht so in
den kabinen wenig oder
nichts spiel genau zum beispiel trachten
genau haben sie selbst der lederhose
habe ich leider nicht aber ich habe
trachtenjacke und brachte neben
anstellen trage ich nicht schön ist auch
schon ich glaube ja und was macht
österreich besonders
ich glaube der gemütlichkeit und
dass man es doch in wien oder
beziehungsweise in österreich sicher ist
super das
was ich mir zu sagen dass in vielen dank
ich hoffe ja heute kontert einen
eindruck gewinnen wie die
österreicherinnen und österreicher so
ticken und was typisch österreichisch
ist wenn ihr etwas habt dass ihr typisch
österreichisch findet schreibt es uns in
die kommentare
und ich sage ich freue mich bis zum
nächsten mal habe die erde
[Musik]